he's the hall-of-famer one of the great
shooters in the history of the game he's
Reggie Miller the Turner Sports NBA
analyst reg will be on the call with
Kevin Harlan for tonight's game five
between the Jazz and Rockets that's
eight Eastern on TNT
good morning reg how are you good good
morning theater I know what we're going
to lead off in okay all I can say is
this as a player you live for moments
like that you live for moments like that
I mean that is
that's why sports in general it's a drug
because you can buy that it's hard to
capture that and that emotion that
lillard those fans and on the flip side
that the Thunder are feeling you can't
buy that anywhere you can't bottle that
you have to go through it wasn't a good
shot absolutely if you look at his shots
throughout that whole series he was
consistently knocking down 27 28 footer
so what's a 37 footer yeah but I got
Paul George on him one of the better
defenders and it's from 37 feet when the
score is tied now I know that the worst
case scenario you go into overtime I win
the overtime I was just surprised he
settled for The Hobbit if there's any
criticism which is by Paul George you
had a chance because you were looking at
the clock at the other end
so you knew once the shot clock maybe
got down to four or five seconds there
was no way he was gonna drive you knew
he was gonna pull up I probably would
have closed the distance a little bit
and made the contest a little bit more
difficult yeah that's how it would have
been a little bit closer to him because
you knew he wasn't going to drive you
knew this was going to be a jump shot in
my opinion is it a bad shot for Damian
Lillard for Steph Curry no for the other
400 plus members of the Association yes
I thought he did something really sneaky
because you watch Paul George and he's
watching the clock and he goes up before
Lillard
but Willard steps to the side just a
little just a live edge and that's all
these great players need and he was just
clearing space so he could get a better
view at the basket look I was watching
the game in bed doing my notes for the
you know this Houston Utah series when
the Thunder went up 15 I said to myself
all right it's a wrap
I can turn off the TV and there was a
voice in the back of my head that said
you had been in moments just like this
and plus I wanted to keep the game on
because I wanted to see if there was
gonna be any extracurricular you know
talking or join if this game was to go
back to OKC so I was like all right let
me just leave it on and watch and then
it got down to like you know 11 and then
8 I was like this this game is not over
and then a series of miscues by defender
first of all Paul George misses two free
throws you don't expect that from you
know a go-to player the offensive foul
on on Westbrook just just some mental
mistakes by the Thunder down the stretch
which left the door open and was closed
by Damian Lillard
all right the thunders future is what
well you have two cornerstones obviously
in Paul George and Westbrook to me
you've got to find more consistent
shooting now I know the last two ball
games they did a better job of shooting
threes but it all season long the
Thunder were a very poor 3-point
shooting team and and that's includes
for Westbrook so you've got to get
better shooting surrounding those guys I
mean you've got a staple in the middle
and Steven Adams I'm sure everyone's
gonna you know call the arms and trying
to get rid of Billy Donovan I think he's
the perfect guy for this job but this
has to hurt and it's gotta sting because
the game was right you know they were
doing a lot of talking after
one game our focus was going for and it
showed it showed the difference between
guys being happy with one game and guys
trying to complete a series talking to
Reggie Miller be on the call with Kevin
Harlan tonight Game five jazz Rockets
8:00 Eastern on TNT reg Fritz he's been
working on his Kevin Harlan
impersonation Fritzie are you ready
a three-pointer by Magritte freakin it's
now nine to six
what do you think I think he should keep
his day job he has a really good gig
with you and being again ed it it's nice
and all I will take this to Harlan and I
will kind of let him play this out okay
wait reg when you go to dinner with
Kevin Harlan when he orders Fritzie how
do you think Kevin Harlan orders dinner
and all the people I've worked with
because I've worked with some great ones
more people come up to Harlan and ask
them to be on their answering machine so
many fans come up and say can you please
beat the voice of my answering machine
and he obliges a lot of that's oh yeah
it's very good but that would be kind of
a jolting thing when you go to your
voicemail Reggie is not err you know be
like little legendary voice yeah all
right let's look at the east here are
the raptors a real threat here like who
is the real threat in the east right now
the way their plan if you were gonna say
that's the team that I would I would
Bank on this is arguably the best Final
Four in the East we've had in a long
time because with LeBron going to the
Lakers I've got to say it's wide open
each team can make a case but each team
is a little green as well the Celtics
were inconsistent all year
but found out found their groove come
playoff time but if you look at those
first few games versus Indiana they were
down Indiana just couldn't score and
you've got Kyrie and they found their
shooting Jason Tatum and Jalen Brown
play much better so they can make a case
Yanis the best record in the league
they've just been smooth and consistent
is Ellis the best player in the game no
no because he still can't shoot so no I
won't say he's the best player because
that deficiency because we're gonna see
in this round now because the further
you go in the playoffs the better the
teams become you start to take away
things and we're gonna see because you t
you the celtics are going to dare and
beg him to shoot those three all right
here's the question reg yeah the player
you would start your team with today is
who probably Greek freak because of the
upside but it was better than him who is
better than him because he can't shoot
from distance although he's gotten a lot
better is Durant the best player in
basketball
I like Durant I like curry I like LeBron
after looking at Damian Lillard can you
go wrong i I think Gregg free-cos past
LeBron because LeBron doesn't play
defense and Greg freak could be the
Defensive Player of the Year not a good
easy defensive player of the year he can
lead the league in score and MV be MVP
something only Michael Jordan did in
1988 which we highlighted in our game
but let's not forget another player that
always gets overlooked who's playing
fantastic in these playoffs Kawhi
Leonard I could I could start a team
with Kawhi Leonard as well and we will
see those highlighted versus the
Philadelphia 76ers to me that that is
going to be an unbelievable series it
all depends on the health of Joel embiid
is going to be able to place 30 plus
minutes because he's gonna have to be on
the court and the good thing there's no
back to back so he'll have time to rest
but he's gonna have to play 30 plus
minutes you can't be playing 25 to 28
minutes versus Gasol and by Serge Ibaka
and those guys he's gonna have to be on
the court he's gonna have to be
effective the Rockets are my pick in the
West but they make me nervous because
they have these moments where you go
what are they doing and who are these
guys because you can't do that in the
next round here are the Rockets any are
they better this year than they were
last year when they went to the Western
Conference Finals I think they're more
confident having gone through those
those trials and tribulations of being
up in that Conference Finals versus the
eventual champs in Golden State and I
think they're a little a little ticked
off a little bit so if they can make
shots like they've done and their
defense I think has started to come back
of last year's when they had not only
the best offense but they had the best
defense in terms of percentage I think
they're getting that back to me the way
Eric Gordon has played in this first
round series has been fantastic I think
he's always been the key because you
know what you're gonna get from Harden
as well as Chris Paul but when they had
that third scorer you know in air Gordon
to me that takes them to a different
level so if he can continue to make
shots and make threes PJ Tucker has
found that corner three and he's their
tough guy
I think it's going to be a fascinating
matchup yeah let's just assume if they
get by Utah which and we we assume they
will that sets up an unbelievable
semifinals with this Golden State I'm
also trying to figure this out with the
Lakers you didn't think you could skate
without a Laker question here I you know
but but reg when it comes to the Lakers
why are they interviewing these guys you
know does Jason Kidd deserve to be the
Lakers head coach maybe interviewed and
you do somebody a favored ty lue does he
deserve to be I mean this is the Lakers
here Monty Williams would be an
interesting pick and probably would be
my pick but you know he may take the
Phoenix job if he gets it so why aren't
the Lakers going after big names or you
know something different
then then what they're going you know
they're interviewing here for their head
coaching position okay well I'm going to
come back and ask
who are those other big names do well
are their assistant coach to go after
are their assistant coaches on the Spurs
or some of these winning teams you said
big names you can't even name one one
big assistant coach name okay how about
how about no big names but somebody who
is maybe a better choice then recycled
coaches is tyloo the best it you can get
he's out of out of a job now Jason Kidd
is out of a job now at least Monty
Williams has a job and you know maybe
John Howard but these guys haven't
coached before I don't know I'm just a
lot the last two names you said month
Monty Williams Juwan Howard I and money
ones has been a head coach before and
has experience I like giving Juwan
Howard a shot here right I mean he's
been in a long time assistant with the
heat a winning culture learning under
Riley and under Spoelstra so why not but
I can't fault the Lakers for wanting to
talk to you know Jason Kidd a Hall of
Fame player and now when he was a coach
he coached he honest correct in the
early development yeah but well
Budenholzer came in there and turned the
same roster around they won 60 games I
don't mind the interview because it's
just an interview you're getting all
caught up in the interview process I
mean it's just an interview all right
and then Tyler want a championship with
LeBron in Cleveland yeah he's out of
he's out of a job he's so good he's out
of a job okay you get hired to be fired
you know that have that the cycle of
coaches go you want apologize
they recycle every NFL coach do you want
to probably general and then they become
they go to offensive coordinator and
then they become head coach they get
fired they go be an offensive
coordinator for another team and then
they get hired as a coach that's how it
happened you want to apologize yelled at
me I'm not yelling at you but you did
and you know and all of our years our
relationship I don't know if you've ever
yelled at me
I wasn't even a zero we don't like it
kind of let me go around the room okay I
will apply will apologize we're talking
we're talking loudly okay but not
yelling not yelling talking loudly we're
like an old married couple we are we can
agree to disagree we're you know we're
not always on the same page but the end
of the days we have love and respect for
one another that's what a married couple
is all about okay what of the four kids
that I have here if we if we split up
who would be our favorite know which two
do you want I would want I want fritzy
because I deal with him the most in
booking and I want I want Paul II want
you to come do I get to live in Malibu
Pauly's he's done that's it see you
Paulie
good night I'm gonna get your room
already what are your colors you like
again red and blue right I'm gonna get
them all ready for you Paulie
bears colors or Chicago Bulls they're
gonna be a lot of Michael Jordan Walter
Payton stuff on the walls yes there will
okay I'll be Kato I'll be in the back
I'll be hanging out all right tell Kevin
Harlan we set a low and absolutely
gentlemen thank you thank you so much
Thank You Reggie that's Reggie Miller
for more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV streamed
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app